but there are many situations where
women have falsely used men of things
and they have gone to jail for it
that's the narrative to say to take away
for the fact of how many people are
great and how many people don't go to
prison for it it's easy to say oh yeah
okay okay I'll give you an example there
is a guy in the U.S he was in college
and a girl said that he raped her or
that she that he raped her right and
then they released security footage of
her pulling him back to the dorm kissing
him
um he was pulling away from her she
still kissed him pulling him back to her
dorm and he still got kicked out of
college because that's terrible yeah but
I'm saying I'm saying to you that's
terrible I'm not saying that that's what
I'm saying and I'm saying what I would
say is there are situations as a woman
you should try not to put yourself in